[Music]
hey can you turn it up
I feel like neo why because you're the
chosen one it could be the chosen one
you don't know but no that's not what I
meant
what did you mean just that the world
feels off to me like how it's kind of
hard to explain it like it's artificial
somehow like we're dreaming all this
through computer system and our physical
bodies are just being used as batteries
no I don't know I don't know that's the
point I mean I just know that
something's wrong something not right
with the world
yeah it's called humanity it's like
we're living in an artificial world
oblivious to the real world what's going
on all around us I think you just
watched too many sci-fi movies didn't
you do a marathon like last weekend
sci-fi film yeah did Matrix Dark City
the 13th floor Inception and men in
black yeah all movies that deal with
alternate realities yeah look at your
point it's like whenever you watch a
bunch of scary movies and then you want
to climb into my bed and sleep because
you're scared you watched all these
movies that have a fake reality and now
you're convinced that your reality is
fake you're talking yourself into this
can't you see that's possible well what
did you wear what happened there was an
orange cat and then another one just
like it
how much like it was it the same cat I'm
a teacher who is usually glue to the
matrix you calm down we have two orange
cats they're twins
remember oh yeah yeah right
for a second in my world almost came
crashing down around me was it matter if
it's all fake anyway so you're admitting
that it's all fake no I was being
sarcastic
you need to learn not to take me so
seriously you know sarcasm is also
usually a glitch in the matrix I'm with
the guy in the Hat they're both wearing
hats the guy on the right the guy in the
beanie that figures
he's even stupider than you are Thanks
[Music]